[Music]
game night so game night stars Jason
Bateman and Rachel McAdams they're one
of three couples who play game night
together and Jason Bateman's more
successful brother comes along and a new
game night happens like a murder mystery
but it's a kidnapping but the game
becomes real because there were real
criminals and no one knew that so it was
kind of this the man who knew too little
thing going on but is that we have a
comedy adventure about a game night this
movie cracked me up a more than I
thought away I always underestimate how
funny Jason Bateman is but also Rachel
McAdams subtly are they funny but they
work well together as a couple not just
a game night parody it's a couples
paradise so many couples out there and
or groups of friends will connect with
this movie let me now to be game night
it could be video game night I think
that impressed me about this movie is
that everybody really added to the
comedy it was not a wasted person in
here or wasted couple they all made me
laugh they all added to the comedy it
takes a step or two past the line of
believability or in a few steps pass a
line of believability to the point where
some of them start acting kind of stupid
you're like you can't you're dumb one
dude in particular this dude was an
unbelievable idiot idiocy to a baffling
degree but it works for him and damn it
he cracks me up - they got Todd from
Breaking Bad in this movie because
there's just something creepy about the
guy I don't know if it's because a lot
of us saw him for the first time in
Breaking Bad and from then on we're like
you're a weirdo now doesn't matter what
you do you're always gonna be the one
who shot her in the back of the head
dick but they play that up with him and
it completely works the movie starts to
falter earlier on in the movie when they
break the crew ups like couples split
off and start doing different things I
was like oh no no you had like a
powerhouse group why'd you break him up
end up bringing him back together and
like one taked almost like they're all
split up all right now they're back
together in a living room that was fast
that was weird but it was also
convenient I'm gonna go ahead and look
past the fact that it happened on a dime
did the job got it done there is a lot
happening in this movie - it's on the
verge of being too convoluted for me
didn't quite breach it still stayed in
the fun zone
I don't always bring things up because
they bother me I bring them up because
they might bother you but this movie is
a comedy and it had me laughing a lot it
kind of reminded me of Jumanji alright
it's nothing like Jumanji I gotta
explain that it's like Jumanji in the
sense that when I went into Jumanji I
was like this is gonna be stupid I
walked out like wow that was a
remarkably fun time same thing
happened with this movie completely
unrelated to Jumanji when did this movie
going okay we'll see what happens it's
gonna be like the house it very well
might be walked out having a great time
I suppose it doesn't hurt that this
movie has in its comedic moments and
delivery a personal favorite of mine
movie references
yep among the comedy has a lot of movie
references at that point is kind of
playing into my own personal bias but
what can I say
it got me even I'll say a cameo from
somebody I was glad to see this person
because big fan and seen him in a while
I don't know it's glad Sam that's as
specific as I can get cuz again I feel
like it's a cameo can spoil a cameo he's
big enough spoiling I feel like the
trailer gives away way too much of the
movie so stay away from the trailer if
you can what you need to know about game
night is this game that was a good
comedy remarkably funny great chemistry
among everybody in it cracked me up I
genuinely believe if you go see game
night this weekend you will have a good
time no alcohol required that's a heart
in a - I like that just a youthful
adventure with people who aren't you
know 20 anymore right so game night have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's a surprisingly enjoyable movie
that you thought was gonna suck whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]